hi I'm Erik Bosse the Marvel Studios
face for now finally has an official
lineup with Kevin Feige you're making a
little cameo in a comic-con do announced
the schedule of MCU films the streaming
series on Disney plus and as a breaker
downer of every goddamn word out of this
man's mouth I feel like a short-order
chef who just got speed read and order
for a total of 12 so I'm gonna break
down everything we learned about
Marvel's future at comic-con why Marvel
didn't lock in anything with the
guardians of the galaxy spider-man a
black panther just yet and how all of
those titles could fit into the MCU
lineup in the years after this announced
schedule and spoiler warning against any
of my predictions I make ruin your life
somehow
okay Black Widow will be the next big
Marvel release with the film dropping on
May 1st 2020 and now 10 months is a long
time between Marvel films I guess we'll
just have to fill the time with Avengers
endgame rewatch --is I think we'll have
time to like watch it twice an update on
Black Widow Scarlett Johansson is
finally playing the Tasha Romanov as the
title character in her own story which
looks like a kind of prequel flashback
to perhaps the mid-2000s pre Avengers
era since you know post Avengers she did
at least part of the story will be set
in Budapest the mysterious mission that
she and Hawkeye have alluded to a couple
times in Avengers movies joining her
will be Florence pew as Yelena Bulova a
sister figure to Natasha who in the
comics is a rival KGB assassin to try to
take the title of Black Widow from her
Rachel vices playing a character named
Melina perhaps a nod to Melina Vostok
oov aka Iron Maiden who in the comics is
another Russian agent from the Red Room
who lived in Black Widow shadow resented
her over the years before she became a
freelance mercenary now another villain
has been announced in this film as
taskmaster which we had rumoured aka
Tony masters he's known for his ability
to mirror and reciprocate every move an
attack from his combatants stranger
things David Harbor is playing Alexi
probably a nod to Alexi Shuster Cove
okay a red Guardian a Russian super
soldier counterpart to Captain America
harbor appeared on the haul age stage in
a Captain America shirt and teased that
he had complicated feelings for cap that
we'll learn more about and Handmaid's
Tale o teyfik Ben Lee is playing Mason
and Ally from Natasha's pre shield past
who might have romantic feelings for
they showed some of director Kate
shortland footage at Comic Con
I'll actually break down what hall
attendees saw in another episode but
let's move on to the next movie on the
MCU lineup the Eternals releasing
November 6 2020 also get more to the
Eternals in a future episode but
essentially they are advanced beings who
were created by the Celestials in the
process to birth sentient life on Earth
with the Eternals defending earth in a
war with their counterparts the deviants
Angelina Jolie will star as Tina and
Richard Madden and Gabe Robb Stark from
Game of Thrones will play Icarus Camille
Nanjiani will play King go Lauren red
lava is gonna play in Macari Brian Tyree
Henry is fastest and Salma Hayek as
their leader a Jack and Leah McHugh as
sprite and Don Lee as Gilgamesh and a
Chloe Zhao is directing but also around
this time streaming service Disney Plus
will launch its first MCU series the
Falcon in the Winter Soldier this will
be in fall 2020 Anthony Mackie and
Sebastian Stan will star in on a Hall H
stage they joked over who gets to hold
caps shield suggesting that might be a
running theme of the series Mac he also
said that he would be wearing some
version of cap suit in the series and
very interesting Lee Civil War villain
Baron Zemo appeared on screen saying
that he'll see us soon he was wearing
his purple mask from the comics that he
never wore in the movie so it looks like
Daniel Bruhl will also appear in this
series as a villain remember he was left
alive at the end of civil war next up
there's the film shang-chi in the legend
of the ten rings released in February 12
2021 Sima Lewis playing shang-chi the
martial arts expert an assassin from the
Marvel Comics and the villain of this
story is going to be the Mandarin now
played by Tony Liu remember a version of
the Mandarin was played by Ben Kingsley
in Iron Man 3 but we learned in that
movie that he was a patsy just an actor
posing as this terrorist figure Marvel
has hinted that they had future plans
for the real Mandarin and this looks to
be it and the ten rings is a terrorist
group that we've seen the MCU before the
Mandarin was associated with them and
they were the group who kidnapped Tony
Stark in the first Iron Man aquafina is
also playing a role in shang-chi because
Hollywood has decided to put her and
everything now shortly after Shane G's
release Disney Plus will release one
division sometimes spring 2021 with
Scarlet Witch Wanda Maximoff Elizabeth
Olsen and the vision Paul Bettany now
this will be set after the events of
Avengers in game but the stars of the
show did not reveal how the hell vision
will come back from being a lifeless
stone list grey Android husky but they
into that the story will get weird and
tiana Paris's co-starring as an adult
version of Monica Rambeau the young girl
in Captain Marvel also around the same
time the Loki's series will drop on
Disney Plus as well sometimes spring
2021 Tom Hiddleston will play the
version of Loki who stole the tesseract
and Avengers endgame and created his new
branch timeline and the panel pointed
out that this character is the one right
after getting Hulk smashed in the first
Avengers not the one who evolved in dark
world Ragnarok and infinity war which
essentially means that this Loki's could
be more of an [ __ ] which I'm very
much looking forward to now the series
has been described as Loki affecting
events throughout human history with
some concept art depicting him walking
around in 1975 and they have Rick and
Morty writer Mike Waldron as showrunner
Loki also has a crazy title card that I
look forward to breaking down in the
future video now next is the movie title
that I am most excited for but before I
continue think you do honey for
sponsoring this breakdown honey's the
easiest way to save money when you're
shopping online I don't know about you
but when I used to see the promo code
box during checkout I'd feel some like
major promo write something here maybe I
could just type please make it cheaper
oh god they're onto me right run run run
run
yeah always felt like I was paying more
than I shouldn't be paying if there is a
discount option here I want to know what
it is thankfully now I have honey it's a
free browser extension that scans the
internet for coupon codes and then like
magic it automatically applies the best
one to your cart at checkout honey will
find you every coupon code sale or
discount on over 20,000 sites like
Amazon eBay all Express Best Buy j.crew
and more and a lot of people are saving
money with honey honey tested over 1
billion promo codes last year and
applied over 185 million working codes
to people's orders and subscribers have
already saved over 47,000 dollars using
honey in other words cha and also change
I use to anyone about a couple pizzas
from Papa John's online I saved like $8
68 cents folks it made all 16 of those
slices taste even better an installation
is super easy just go to join honey calm
slash new rock stars and then two clicks
later there you go installed and honey's
for everyone because it works for
practically anything you buy online and
again downloading it is easy it only
takes two clicks to install look there's
really no reason not to download honey
free to use and easy to install on your
computer in just two clicks never over
think about the promo code box again get
honey for free at join honeycomb slash
new rock stars that's join honey calm
slash new rock stars and thank you again
Tony for sponsoring this breakdown okay
back to the next title on the marble
face for lineup Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness releases a May 7
2021 director scott derrickson whose
background is as a horror film maker has
said that this sequel will be a gothic
horror film and will be the ensues first
scary movie and Kevin Feige has
confirmed that despite Quentin pecks
lies about the multiverse the Spider Man
far from home the multiverse is still
very much an existing thing in the MCU
derrickson has said that he wants the
villain to be nightmare a demonic entity
that feeds on people's negative emotions
while they sleep and joining this cast
will be Scarlet Witch with her character
arc and Wanda vision directly affecting
her role in the multiverse of madness
which is a title I cannot say enough
following this Disney Plus will release
this series what if in summer 2021 what
if will be an animated anthology series
based on the hypothetical spin-off comic
series with pretty much all the past MCS
stars on the table to return and voice
their characters the first episode is
rumored to be what if Peggy Carter got
the Super Soldier Serum this would be
hosted by Jeffrey Wright as the watcher
remember watchers are the god-like
cosmic beings who observe all events in
the universe in multiverse some watchers
actually made little cameos with Stan
Lee in guardians the galaxy vol 2 next
Disney Plus will released the Hawkeye
series in fall 2021 with Jeremy Renner
returning as Clint Barton now mentoring
Kate Bishop the character he passes the
Hawkeye torch on to in the Marvel Comics
and around this time the Thor for film
that we've been talking about will
release officially titled Thor love and
thunder on November 5th 2021 Chris
Hemsworth and Tessa Thompson are
returning in a new story set after the
events of Avengers endgame Taika Waititi
is returning to direct and perhaps once
again voice in mocap as korg he said
he's pulling from Jason Aaron's comic
series The Mighty Thor which introduces
a female Thor Jane Foster and Thor 11
thunders bringing back Natalie Portman
as Jane Foster to play this role I'll
dig more into this and how great this
could be in another episode
now according to Kevin Feige all of what
I've just talked about constitutes the
complete phase for but he has said that
things might change
remember when he announced phase 3 back
in 2014 that lineup didn't yet include
spider-man homecoming or spider-man far
from home or a man in the wasp and a did
feature and Inhumans movie that got
canceled but Feige did confirm that
Black Panther - Captain Marvel - and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 are still
very much in the pipeline as are a
Fantastic Four reboot and something with
the mutants meaning x-men and most
thrillingly
a blade film with Maher saleh ali in the
role but when will all this come out
well looking ahead past this phase 4
lineup I wouldn't be surprised if we saw
a second black panther film in February
2022 guardians of the galaxy vol 3 in
May 20-22 and maybe another spider-man
in summer 2022 with maybe Captain Marvel
dropped in November 22 or sometimes
spring 2023 remember spider-man is a
Sony property so Marvel Studios has to
be careful making any firm plans for his
future and they're most likely waiting
until after far from home inevitably
crosses the billion dollar mark in the
box office before thinking about that
and I think guardians vol 3 was
originally going to be part of this
phase 4 line about that whole drama with
James Gunn last summer delayed things
with gun taking on Suicide Squad - for
DC in that period that he was still
fired from Disney and that Suicide Squad
sequel is gonna come out in 2021
so now guardians volume 3 will most
likely come out the following year 2022
or later now between Fantastic Four and
x-men
I think rebooting the Fantastic Four
would definitely come first since fans
have had more time to forget about past
film adaptations and I would argue there
is a greater need for them an MCU at
this moment so maybe we'll see a
Fantastic Four movie as soon as summer
2023 again this is stuff I'm not getting
anywhere it's just my predictions based
off of what properties they have when
they'll have them and when makes the
most sense to release them and Feige has
clarified that this blade movie with
Maher xolali will probably be phase 5 so
I'm thinking 20 23 or beyond for that
but which of these upcoming Marvel
releases are you most excited for
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA boss and subscribe to the
rockstars to breakdowns of Marvel and
comic-con news thank you for joining me
in no no they won't have a Marvel film
for another ten months let's see how
I'm getting that tough no screw it I can
just love ice cream too much
[Music]